a signal processing group
and so i designed
my training
sorry actually i i just one thing
changed could you just restart that but
go for it
okay
uh thanks for the introduction then my
name is bertie fries i'm a professor in
eindhoven at eindhoven
university of technology in the
netherlands
i'll be a part of
an electrical engineering department in
a signal processing group so we designed
signal processing algorithms and about
six seven years ago i read
for the first time a paper by carl
fiston it was called a rough guide to
the brain
and struck me that this could be
fantastic for signal processing so since
then i'm really trying to work with
people in my lab
on realizing realizing agents that will
design will automate the design process
of signal processing algorithms and as
you know we're doing this by message
passing and we want to talk about that
today
uh thais
yeah um my name is tyson i'm a poster
with bird's lab i did my phd also an
active inference on how to automate
those processes and uh also together
with michael cox and all the colleagues
from the lab we built the toolbox called
fornilab and i'll be talking and walking
you through um how we apply that in an
active infra con inference context um
and do some cool things with that
and so that's for later
yeah hello everyone so my name is nitri
bhagav i'm a phd candidate in bias lab
also in hue in university and yeah my
work is mostly about reactive message
pricing based bayesian inference
that we hope will help with active
inference as well but that's also for
later i will talk about it
on my
uh time yeah my slot
cool thank you
okay um
shall i uh go then and do a little
introduction a few slides
let's see that
yeah okay um
let's see if i can share my
slide
yep looks good
yeah okay
so
the
first slide is uh eindhoven
um because you may wonder where is i
know in relation to amsterdam well it's
about
100 kilometers south of amsterdam close
to the belgian border and not so far
away from germany either
um
so it's a it's sort of a high-tech city
phillips
originated and opened on the right
bottom you see a picture of the center
and the right top is a view of the
campus of our
university of technology
here's an aerial view of groups
going through five here's an aerial view
of our campus
and uh so
here let's see if i can share a pointer
yeah so uh this is the building for
electrical engineering so this is where
we are
ios lab is short for bayesian
intelligent autonomous systems that's
what we try to build
we have about three
let's say staff members faculty members
and currently six phd students dmitry is
one of those pc students
and we have open positions if there are
people watching that are interested in
probabilistic programming or how to make
active inference work
then what are we trying to do this is a
picture that's probably familiar to
everybody in this uh forum right this is
uh this wants to show that well the only
thing that's really going on in the
brain is
for energy minimization or expected free
energy minimization
to do everything
and that's a huge inspiration to us to
us engineers so what we try to do is
basically this we want to put this in an
iphone or on a raspberry pi
and let a robot
learn how to ride a bike
but the beauty of this framework for
engineering purposes is that it's almost
one solution approach to to to any
problem so
if we can do it you could teach a robot
how to write a
energy minimization probably we can also
apply this in virtual reality and design
algorithms for hearing aids or even
self-driving cars
the the big
let's say
promise or the attractiveness for
engineering is that it it's just one
always the same thing you just have to
propose a model and minimize the free
energy
no matter what the application is but
it's very uh
appealing
the problem for engineering is that this
energy functional
is a function of observations and
observations are streaming data coming
usually
well could be at
every millisecond so it's a highly time
varying function
and the number of latent variables let's
say the space of latent variables is
usually very high so we have a very high
dimensional function that is time
varying
and
we want to minimize that now the brain
is very good at it right the brain has
uh what is a 10 to the power of 14
synapses 100 billion euros
but a normal
optimization library and model up or
python will not cut it you cannot
minimize a time varying function of
thousand variables in
matlab it's not going to work
so we need something quite radical here
and the idea we go with is not that
radical again we just take inspiration
from the brain right the brain is a
network of message passing and turns out
in my own field
in signal processing
or information theory to be exact
this has been formalized there's a paper
here by
dave forney in 2001
codes on graphs normal realizations he
called it normal factor graphs but in
honor of david forney there today
they're called forney style factory
graphs
and
so this is the origin of the factor
graphs that we are talking about and a
few years later
hans andreia luliger at the university
in series
uh i have made this
popular in the signal processing
community and already around 2007 you
see in in his papers these uh
yeah these typical structures like this
that we will show also later these are
kalman filters
this is really also what tristan talks
about these kinds of structures so
um this is uh
what we want to do in our language is to
combine what
active inference from the inspire
inspiration from the neuroscience
community and combine it with what we
know in signal processing and
information theory about factor graphs
and use these tools to to implement this
uh so today
we have two presentations one by text
from the line
uh on how to do message passing by
forney lab forney lab is the toolbox
that we wrote
uh you know
the name of course refers to the forney
uh and thais will show how to do active
influence with this toolbox
then we're also working on a new version
it's called reactive message passing and
dmitry is the main person there and
dimitri also
i'll talk about that a bit
and that's all for me
um i'll give it back to you dan or maybe
uh
can continue what is your preference
i'll
stop sharing my screen
see
super interesting thanks a lot for the
context and
it will be awesome to hear from the
authors with maybe any reflections on
those general points you raised and how
it gets applied in a really specific way
because you brought up a ton of topics
that we talk about all the time like the
simplicity of one unified approach and
the challenges of ongoing optimization
problems and drawing inspiration from
nature so great things i think we can
just jump to whichever
of the presentation
you all prefer
all right then i'll go ahead and try to
share my screen
see if that works
[Music]
select windows screen entire screen okay
a lot more
practical streams i think you can see my
screen now yep
you can make it look just large on your
side and i'll resize it there we go
looks great
there we go all right
well thanks again for having us can you
click away i will be giving a little
introduction sorry where it says you're
sharing your um screen you could hide
that little jitsi thing
um and it's gone
thank you
so um yeah i'll be giving a little
introduction on how to
do message passing with phony lab in the
context of active inference
and to give a little bit of motivation
for this talk um this is kind of the
situation where we're interested in so
we have some kind of an environment
and we have an environmental process
that's running in that environment and
we want to develop an agent that has
some purpose or does some purposeful
task within that environment
and the agent is allowed to
send actions to the environment and
manipulate that environment and it will
receive observations
and in the environment process there is
some
function rt that is running there and it
might be simulation that we run that we
interact with that or it might be even a
real world process of which of course we
don't really know what rt is running in
the real world and somehow we want to
build an agent that does something
in that world
so where do you start with that
there's this paper from conant and ashby
in the 1970s
and they have an interesting theorem
that says that
every good regulator of a system must be
a model of that system
so
that actually means that if you want to
build an agent
that regulates or
manipulates our system the environment
then we have to model that system
so as an
engineer we are in the business
of building models
generative models to be precise
and this model represents our belief
about
how observations
follow from our manipulations
we represented by a function f that is a
function of y the observations
the controls u
and also some latent state hidden
variables x
that act as intermediate between
observations and controls
now
reasoning forward is one thing but in
the end what we want to do is observe
things and then propose controls that
lead us to favorable states
and that is where
the idea of the free energy principle
and active inference comes in
so if we want
to see this is the hypothesis so that if
we want to build an agent that does
something purposeful then we can do that
by minimizing a free energy bound on
surprise
so we want to build an agent that avoids
surprises and by that we can do bayesian
inferences about that environment
so we have to build some kind of free
energy functional
for the agent to optimize
and by that duration inferences for
actions and controls
[Music]
and we defined as for energy functional
as a kl divergence between the
generative model that we have
and some kind of an approximate
posterior that we postulate that we here
define q t
and minimizing this energy functional
will then allow us to reason backwards
from observations towards controls
that's kind of the general idea
and
having postulated this i have choices to
make
so for example one big choice that i
want to make is how do i choose my model
how do i choose my f
in such a way that
is useful to me
and also how do i choose my qut
how do i choose the factorization of
that
such that i can make my inferences
and
that process is kind of a thing of trial
and error
and um
as an engineer i want of course to build
the best model that i possibly can
but how how do i go as quickly as
possible through a process of trial and
error that gives me the best mark the
best model
and this is where the idea of a model
design cycle comes in
and this was again made popular by david
bly
in his paper in 2014 built compute
critique repeat
and he proposes a cycle where an
engineer proposes a model
and then with that model you want to
infer your quantities of interest given
data
and if you have infer the model like
that you want to criticize it
and based upon
well the performance that you have
evaluated you want to reiterate rebuild
your model
infer
again
and see how well it then performs
until you're satisfied and you can apply
it in your agent in in practice maybe in
a real world setting
and then the challenge becomes then how
do i go through this design cycle as
quickly as possible
so we want to be flexible we want to
automate things
and making model proposals itself is
something
that well you have to do as an as an
engineer you have to come up with a
proposal of
how you believe the world functions
but once you have that
everything else can be automated
you can infer these quantities by
probabilistic programming you can
evaluate the free energy as a measure of
model performance
[Music]
and
automating this cycle will be the key to
making model proposals for an agent that
will be useful in practice so you want
to go through this as quickly as
possible
so that's why we choose a specific
method we choose vector graphs
to represent our factorized models
because
in a graph you can do manipulations you
can add nodes delete nodes you can
rewire things very
quickly and once you have a graphical
representation of your model you can do
message passing on that graph in order
to automate the inference
and you can even evaluate free energy by
local contributions in that
graph so that is why we choose a
graphical representation and that is why
we want to do message passing because we
want to design models quickly
so that we can design effective agents
now how do these graphs
kind of work right how do you build an
effective graph or what does that look
like
so we choose a specific representation
of our model
and this is an example where we have a
generative model of five variables x1
through x5
and we have three factors f a b and c
and here on the picture on the right is
the graphical representation of that
model
and as you can see the edges correspond
to the variables and the nodes
correspond to the vectors
and the edges are connected to the nodes
of which
the vectors are in arguments so here you
see node fa which connects edges x1 and
x2 well that is because x1 and x2 are
arguments of fa
same for fb and fc
now
how do we do inference in this graph
so suppose that we observe x5
which is indicated by this little solid
square
and we want to compute our belief over
x2 given x5
well what do you do well you marginalize
everything and
by marginalization i mean you integrate
out every variable
except the one that you're interested in
so accept x2
you integrate everything out and you you
add this constraint that you observe x5
now if you have a big model
then this integration becomes very
cumbersome because this here is
you have here four variables of which to
integrate
so
this room this this integration space
that really explodes if you want to do
this naively
but you can be smart about this
you can
re-shuffle these integrals according to
their respective terms
so for example
this integration over x5
well there is only one factor where x5
is an argument of
so i can use the distributive rule to
bring this integral inside
so that i divide these integrals up into
smaller parts which are manageable
and this is where message passing comes
from
message passing is essentially solving
these integrations one by one
so i can first integra integrate out x
x one here for example
which
as we say summarizes all the information
inside this orange box and it gives us a
message first message here that exits
this orange box
then it can continue for the bottom so
integra integrate out x5
and i get a second message
and i can use this second message
in the computation of the third message
so this way you get
a nested solution approach
where i use the the the solution that i
have for the message two in the
computation of message three
and you see that in the end
the multiplication of these two
colliding messages on the edge for x2
will give me
my proportional belief my proportional
posterior
over x2 given what i have observed
so to give a little example of
a specific node how that works
here's an equality constraint node
which we use
as
as a constraint
to
to constrain the beliefs upon the the
adjacent edges to be equal
um and what that does is that they will
follow if we if we go through the math
here
um
this is what the node function looks
like so i say okay it's a function of
three variables x y and z
and i constrain z
to be x and i constrain z also to be y
so
then x will also be y if i constrain
those two to be the same
so let's see if we can derive messages
based on this
so
if i want to summarize the information
into this orange box
i can use the sub-product rule for that
i have the two messages coming in here
from the left and from the bottom
message one and message 2.
i multiplied that by the node function
of the equality node and i want to
perform this integration
now i substitute
this
this node function here with dividing
integration and then i can use the
shifting property
to
kind of replace the arguments here of x
and y with
the arguments of z
so what i have essentially done here is
saying i can compute this message
three by multiplying the two messages
that are incoming from the left and from
the bottom
now if you squint your eyes a bit and
you look uh you look through your eyes
you can kind of recognize
a proportional base rule in here
so essentially you can say well if
message three here represents my
posterior
then message one can represent my prior
a message to my likelihood
and then i have a proportional posterior
message three and then i can pass on to
the rest of my model
and this node is also often used to kind
of combine information that's coming
from the left and from the bottom
um
so this is a very quick introduction to
do message passing
um we have derived lots of rules also
from the literature also implemented a
lot of rules that are already derived
into uh into phony lab which is
basically
well a software problem programming
suite that
does the scheduling and
this message computation for you
so you don't have to think about that
too much how to redistribute these
integrals and how to derive
well a lot of updates for specific nodes
um so that's kind of
the things that that we can we can
automate
uh on that side of the uh of the design
cycle
now
other any questions about this because
i'm going through this very quickly and
what i'm going to do next is kind of
want to walk through an example
so maybe this is kind of a natural point
where people have questions that they
can kind of stop me and think hey you're
going to fast here
i think it'll be good to see the example
and then we have some questions in the
live chat and also anyone's welcome to
add more
all right sure sure
so how do you do this in practice
in an active inference context so this
is a little example it's called the
bayesian thermostat
where we have an environment environment
so
where we have a heat source here on the
left and we have a little car that can
move around it can move away from the
heat source or it can move towards the
heat source
now the position relative to heat source
is what we call x
and at every position there is a
specific temperature
um
and temperature that we measure at a
specific position is what we call y
and we have a preference of being at a
temperature of four
y four i don't know it's something we
choose
now we control control this car by
moving it left or right and our control
this is the velocity that we move left
or right with and it's called
u
so this is our environment
and we want to build a model for that
so
in active interference what we want to
do is
we want to reason
from states where we would like to be
towards controls that we have to apply
at this current at this current time in
order to get there in the future
so what we want to do is we want to
reason forward from the current time
time t
up into
some time horizon big t
and
in the future we want to consider
how the agent will move
and where we want that agent to be at
that time and in the end we will want to
be at a temperature of four
and that's a state space model that
represents our belief for how this agent
will
move itself through the world
so at time t we have an observation
coming in of a specific temperature
and maybe we have already made an action
um and
we say that
the current state xt relates to the
previous state and action that we have
by by adding so basically ut here is a
velocity that we add to our current
position
um in in one time step and then we get
kind of our next position
by just adding that and also applying
some gaussian noise
and so we have a state transition that
is this additive with uh
with duty saying i want to move forward
to the left or four to the right um and
then we add some gaussian noise saying
okay we're kind of uncertain about
um how this agent might move in the
environment
we have an idea about that but let's add
some variants in order to
account for some uncertainties
and then we say here with this vertical
line that if we have
um an observation
or if we have a position then it relates
to an observation of the temperature
well
-1 it's kind of a rough guess it's just
saying well
if i move to the right if i move away
from my heat source then my temperature
will decline
with a slope of minus one
and it's kind of a really rough guess in
the real world there will be a very nice
temperature gradient that maybe will
move like
will move very slowly downwards
um but we're just saying hey we don't
really know what that is let's make a
rough guess we have a belief this is our
generative model our belief about the
world let's just say that temperature
decreases with position
and again we're not very certain about
that so let's again add
some gaussian noise
and now i extend this
into the future so i say actually well i
believe that in the future my
environment will also evolve
according to this
but
i also have some ideas about where i
want to be
and this is where gold priors come in
that constrain my future observations of
the temperature to be around this
desired temperature of four
and i'm saying then here with some added
noise well um
i want to be around four right it
doesn't have to be exactly but i want to
be pretty certain that um i will be
around four at time t plus 1 and i will
continue
to remain there
until
sometime in the future
now we have regenerative model
and
we can define our energy functional and
we can solve this for energy functional
by message passing on this graph
and we pass these messages towards
our next control
because we're interested in inferring
what we have to do next like from from
from the next time
um and this is where we can do message
passing we can summarize all the
information that we have from
from the past so this will be an
estimate of the current state of the
agent
and it will be biased by our beliefs
about the future saying where we want to
be
and that will influence or determine
which control that we will take
at the present time
or at the next time
all the details of that this are
are described in
this paper from 2019
by
you can also see kind of how we apply
that
within the action perception loop
and things like that
because you will have to do this at
every time t
because your state estimate will change
the word will change according to your
actions so you will for every time you
will have to recompute a new action for
what you're going to do next
um and this is kind of the
the main idea now of course we don't
want to do everything
of this by hand so what we want to do is
well we want to use a tool for that
so now
i'm going to show a little demo of how
you would implement this
um using the the formula probabilistic
programming tool
so let's see if i can
open our little demo so this is uh
this is readable actually or should i
zoom in more
um
you can zoom in a little bit more
maybe like this
uh yeah i can resize it
um
that that's pretty good
oh that's perfect
that's pretty good yep thank you
so this is um so so it's kind of set
what what we want to do
but so this is kind of our definition of
the environment itself so this is the
the real world
well we have this this temperature
gradient which is a very nice function
so very smooth function
where at the heat source we have a
temperature of 100
and it
it goes down with
with with position from the heat source
[Music]
so this is a real world we don't really
know this so this is the one that we're
going to approximate with this
very rough minus one and then
we'll see whether that will work on it
now this is my wonderful ascii art that
has now been resized of basically the
model that i've just shown in the slides
um
and this here is our model definition so
actually i have to zoom out a bit to
make it more readable
yeah so we want to build a graph for
this right so um here we have our
observation states controls
and we define a prior belief
about t minus one so where have we been
which we're going to say is a gaussian
and with some mean and some variance
and then for every time into the future
from uh from one until the horizon
we will have a prior belief about
controls which basically says well
what am i allowed to do when i say okay
well
um
i have a i'll have a gaucho prior about
controls with
a mean of zero
i'll substitute that there and then
maybe some variance
and um
here i say well i have my position of
the agent it relates to my controls by
just
this addition
um
with some added precision gamma so this
is our transition model
this is horizontal
line
and this is our observation model which
is very
rough estimate minus one of the
temperature gradient
times current state and also some
some some precision
conservation precision
and this represents my goal prior
so note that i haven't really put in any
specific values here yet i've just have
placeholders for actual statistics and
values that i'm going to put in
because the actual derivation of my
algorithm doesn't really depend upon the
statistics it's just something that
we can we can put in later
so this is what i want to do build a
free energy functional and the phony lab
is actually just
basically four lines of code
um so this stereo factorization that
defines my factorization for q
saying that um
i'm just going to have
a joint variational distribution
um over the entire graph
i don't really subdivide it into a
structure into a structured
factorization some people are familiar
with that
um but just saying okay i just have this
stereo factorization of the variational
distribution to be my entire graph
and never just one command
i can derive a message passing algorithm
that propagates all the messages towards
control u2 which which which is the
control for the next
time step t plus one
and i want to evaluate my free energy so
also give me at the same time an
algorithm that i can i can execute in
order to evaluate my free energy
and this line will convert this
to
two source code that i can then load in
my environment
and what this does is it builds a
message passing algorithm for us
so this is this this is the code that
executes the message passing on our
graph
and here you can see that it computes
all these messages
by some product rules and other rules
there we have pre-derived and we have
implemented in fornilab
and you can see that these messages they
depend upon the statistics so this is
for example the mean of
of our prior
over states and variance of a prior
overstates
and we have other messages that depend
upon previous messages
in the way that i explained message
passing
and this builds an entire list of in
this case 26 messages
and in the end we're interested in the
marginal beliefs so the posterior
marginal beliefs about about for example
or controls
and you get these beliefs by multiplying
messages together so for example to get
a new belief over the following control
you multiply
messages 9 and 25
and you also recognize this from a
little introduction past introduction
where you have colliding messages on the
edge that you multiply in order to get
your posterior beliefs
and that's what we return in the end
that's what we're interested in
so this is the execution of that
algorithm
and notice that we've made an entire
schedule here and
they can be very cumbersome
can be very long very long schedule and
so that makes it expensive maybe to load
and to execute
and dimitri has the solution for that
and he'll explain that in a minute
um so i'm very happy about building
schedules
and um dimitri not so much uh
and he tries to find uh find a solution
for them get rid of them
um because in the end that will be the
fastest
to really don't
have a schedule that not really had
recipe but just cook by whatever is
given to you
so now we execute this algorithm in
practice so this is our action
perception loop for every time step
we want to
we want to act we want to evoke an
action from the agent we want to execute
that that that action in
the uh in the environment so this is
sending the action towards actual real
world or kind of simulated world in this
case and what we get from that is an
observation
and from our action observation we want
to infer
infer our new action
and also return
the variation of free energy
um
and then prepare for the next step so in
every step we propose an action to the
environment it actually gets executed we
observe a new outcome
we we infer new action
um and we evaluate how well we did with
that action
and then you get well nice plots like
this so
this is the velocity of our agent
we start at zero and you can see that it
moves very quickly to the right
um
and then
it also moves back a little bit um until
the end comes to a stationary point more
or
less um and you can see actually here
what it does so it starts out at a
temperature of 20
then it moves very quickly to the right
away from the heat source
it overshoots its mark
and then it actually goes back and then
it settles around this desired
temperature of four that we have uh
encoded by by our goal priors
um so why does overshoot well our model
of the environment wasn't perfect right
we had this very rough estimate of minus
minus one
um and in the real world was this very
nice smooth kind of complicated function
um
that has this kind of bell shape
so even though
our generative model of the environment
wasn't perfect
um in the end we paid by that pay for
that by overshooting a little bit but
still we were able to get to our desired
state at the temperature of four so in
the end
it kind of worked pretty well
and you can also see that the free
energy of the agent also decreases with
time so we start off at around a
thousand so the scale's logarithmic here
and it decreases very quickly um to our
sum value it's
rather rather low right and then we have
some noise that that induces some
unexpected changes or some unexpected
surprises
um so that's why you have these little
ripples these little ripples here but in
the end we're minimizing free energy and
it's going it's decreasing drastically
so we actually have this free energy
minimizing agent
um
and yeah that's uh that's basically
all i have the story and
and the demo
that was awesome thank you very much we
can uh with screen share on or not ask a
few of the questions from the live chat
and also give people a few seconds to
type more so
i'm just going to jump into the
questions
first let me stop my screenshot
great so we're still sharing the screen
story um we see just the jitsies so go
just click the screen share button again
in jitsi
so awesome thank you so the first
question
is from john and john writes how does
the factor graph approach work if the
graph structure is not known beforehand
is structure learning possible
uh yeah so so that's a good that's a
good question so is structural learning
possible in graphs like these
um
so that is actually something that is
still an active
field of research that would be awesome
if you can automate also the structure
learning of the graph itself
but there are a lot of challenges there
so how do you parameterize this graph
structure um or and and how do you do
how do you do that actually right what
is your search space in terms of graphs
how do you how do you learn node
functions if you don't have a node
function given for your graph right so
these are all very difficult questions
and you don't have a straightforward
answer
so so that's why
this actual model design step in the
design
cycle itself
is still kind of a creative process
there is an engineer that has to come up
with a model
and as an engineer you also have to
think about how to adjust that model if
you're not satisfied with it
so if free energy is still high after
you run your agent well something is
going on something is wrong with your
model it's not an accurate
representation of what is
the environment and then you might
adjust that how do you adjust that well
currently it's still just trial and
error so maybe you can say okay i think
here is still something that i can
improve maybe remove a node maybe the
model is too complex
[Music]
but structure running in itself is um
it is something that is
also it can be addressed so there are
there are methods like um like nested
model comparison and things like that
that you can do in fact graph so you can
for example if you have a nested model
compute savage dickey ratio and then
kind of prune your model based upon that
and so those are things that you can do
to find a complex model and see what you
can cut away
but adding to that model is still
difficult so once you've cut it away
well how do you add yeah i i don't i
don't really know so that's that's a
good question and uh i don't have a very
straightforward and switch you can
from my rattling so yeah
perhaps i can say something about it um
i mean i i totally agree with uh with
taste i mean generally
when you design a
system or signal processing system you
have to design the
structure uh you have to estimate the
parameters and then you have to infer
states right the states change very fast
uh it leads to a common filter and and
that's very
well known in factor graphs
then the next stage would be can we also
over the long term learn parameters
and our effectographs can do that pretty
well
now the the next stage in biology i mean
we know the structure is also alert over
even longer times right
and so that's not working at the moment
in formula you can compare like tests i
says if you have two examples you can
compare the free energy and just pick
the best one
but we are working on that and this is i
mean we're taking again the lead by uh
from carl's idea on bayesian model
reduction but how to implement that in a
factor graph is a research project so
we're we're we're
working on that and i'm not sure where
that will end but that's our goal did
you have phd position available bert so
uh
also to bring it back to the example of
the
motor car getting to an optimal
temperature it's like if every hour you
notice that there was a bump in the free
energy then you go back to the drawing
board and you you go to the people who
are on that car in that area and ask
well what happens every hour or maybe we
do need to include this other source of
information but the model that you had
does its job so you could include the
wallpaper and other features the room
but that's kind of this art and science
of engineering and that's why it's
always interesting to work because
often in research it's like let's finish
the analysis
but really there's this cycle that the
entire
model is embedded within
that helps us always keep an eye out for
those patterns that are
precluding being captured by our current
models
here's just
here's a second question from the chat
how does the factor graph approach work
if the goal temperature in this example
is not defined beforehand can the goal
be abstract so kind of a similar
question but rather than structure
learning how does preference and goal
orientation arise
again excellent question
so
that kind of
relates to the question well who sets
the goals
or how do you set goals
so
yeah
the plain answer to that is well it's an
engineer that defines that
um but it can also be a higher level
agent
that does inference and sets to his
goals
so then you get to kind of
turtles all the way down
argument in the sense well you can put
layer upon layer upon layer upon layer
and layers set goals and other layers as
the goals for that layer etc etc
um
so how that will work in practice um
yeah that's still again um
active research area
um
but in the end it should come down to
minimizing free energy
so so that's kind of the central theme
of this we want to we want to minimize
free energy
we do it by perception we do it by model
learning
um but also learning of the goals
should be driven by minimizing free
energy so you should choose the goals
that minimize for energy well how do you
do that
i don't know
you tell me right
yeah
one more question that was asked was how
or does this integrate with graph
databases
or with large data sets is this
something that scales or is already
integrated to work with that kind of
empirical data or
what
um i think it depends on what you mean
by large data sets
um
so
when i hear large data sets i usually
think about big data things like that
um
so um
this toolbox is specifically built for
dynamic modeling
right so
now in the sense that you have a lot of
features in your data but it's signal
processing so data might come in very
quickly
and you have a model of how these data
change over time
so
in that sense you want to do processing
quickly so you want a lot you want
velocity it's it's based on
processing with velocity
not processing with with volume as for
example other problems programming
toolboxes are excellent at like um
by torch and things like that right
sampling base toolboxes
adword
all great toolboxes if you have a volume
in terms of data and you have for
example an iid model that you want to uh
that you want to fit
um in our sense if we talk about large
data we talk about volume so data that
come in very quickly and we try to be
good at that um phony lab
is not yet that good at it to be
honest um but reactive message passing
is going to be
the bomb
at those kind of of data sets
there's there's also a bit of that
what we we really try to build these
toolbox to build active influence agents
and the idea that you just put these
agents in an environment they make
actions they select their own data
so we don't really
try to build a toolbox that is really
good at just doing machine learning for
a fixed set database
but rather we try to build
models that
let's say dynamic models that can adapt
and that can make actions and that can
in real time process streaming data and
and in that sense over time if you wait
long enough yeah there's a lot of data
streaming through it
but it was sort of generated by you or
at least affected by the agent itself
right
we don't try to optimize for
for big fixed databases rather for just
streaming data in an environment
it's a really fascinating point because
there's a lot of time dependent tasks
like autonomous driving where it's like
okay here's the 500 terabytes of video
or here's this now give me the best
possible score
in a time snapshot and it's it's
every single time with an active
inference agent we're always including
action and policy selection in the loop
and so
how how are we going to deal with that
but that's why the inspiration from
biological systems becomes so important
it's kind of like when people go oh well
the brain must have this processing
power and then if it were a light bulb
or if it was this kind of a silicone
computer it would take up this much
energy ergo's efficiency is such and
such but it's predicated upon
the kind of computers that we're used to
seeing instead of kind of starting with
what already exists and then looking for
an answer that
rests in that rather than how do we make
lower power transistors so that we can
fit them into the brain
so
awesome topics i think we're ready for
the next presentation
yeah hello everyone let me also share my
screen uh for a second
i hope it should work now looks good
so can you see my slides now yes
so okay so yeah hello again my name is
mitri bhagav and i want to introduce you
like this new reactive message passing
based framework for bayesian imprints in
july that we called reactive mp it's
more like our future vision on solutions
for active inference fornilab.jl is like
more like mature
framework it works and reactive mp is
our research project for now
and we are going to start with a
question
what is actually reactive message
busting
and in a
in most senses it's the same message
passing as a formula but re-implemented
in reactive paradigm so basically the
major issue with traditional approaches
in porn lab
is that enable in order to run inference
for our model we need to create this
shadow of messages in advance
so we need to pre-analyze our graph we
need to analyze everything basically and
we do we need to do it every time we
change our graph structure
and if graph is big this graph analysis
time and shadow creation may take a lot
of extra time
and it might be not a big issue but as
an engineer you may want to test a lot
of models until you're satisfied with
the performance and this extra delays
and shuttle creation times that they may
be just a bit of annoying and reactive
message passing last allows us to
eliminate this predefined shadow and
also it gives us a lot of other benefits
and possible future research directions
so instead of having instead of having a
fixed shadow we cast our graph to like
an event-based system
where everything can react on its
neighbor environment
and in terms of message passing
nodes react on incoming messages
and also it reacts on updated posterior
marginals over our parameters
and the whole model becomes reactive we
can also react on changes in this system
and basically do whatever we want so we
may perform some action
based on new updated posterior marginals
it also in message passing a natural
starting point uh is uh our data or
observations and the model itself reacts
on changes in our data or in our priors
and it also changes posteriors
accordingly
so here i outlined some extra benefits
from the active message passive
implementation so first of all we may
outline biological plausibility
because in nature we probably don't have
any predefined scheduler for our
information flowing on neurons in our
brain for example
uh they they are driven like by some
chemistry like physics and in sense it's
like also reactive system it constantly
adapts the changes in an environment
and also it reacts only if needed
and in terms of message passing based
inference it may be unnecessary to even
react in some events like some messages
if they aren't really important
uh a fixed predefined shadow you're
forced to do all computations even if
you don't really need them
uh another great benefit of craft
message busting is that it scales very
nicely for very big graph so it's more
like an answer for previous question
uh so it supports like hundreds of
thousands of factor notes even millions
are possible uh i will show you an
example in a couple of minutes but just
to give you a bit of context so in this
plot we met we modeled just some moving
objects with known line linear dynamics
and the idea was to estimate the sedan
states given noisy observations
in this example i used kalman smoother
with 50 000
observations and this model contains
roughly about 150 000 factor nodes
so bayesian inference on this kind of a
model is impossible on sampling based
inference
but with reactive message passing it
takes only about like
eight seconds on just a home macbook
laptop
so we can go further a bit and make
reactive system robust and tolerant to
some let's say failing nodes or missing
data
from let's say failed sensor
we fix predefined shadow if something
like this happens we need to do
everything from scratch
we need to recreate our model we need to
again make a shadow
and it will just take some time
with reactive message busting we may
just stop reacting on some missing data
or maybe failing sensor
and we can just wait for them to be
available again
it makes it very robust in that sense it
also gives us an opportunity to change
our graph structure in runtime
and still perform inference without
stopping
so there's a slide about how we actually
do that
we use julia's main programming language
in our lab roughly about a year and a
half i believe ago
we wrote the library for reactive
programming in julia so it's completely
unrelated to message passing in just a
general framework for event based
systems
but that allowed us at the later point
to build reactive mp.jl package
and it implements free energy
minimization by message passing
we also introduced graphpl.gel package
that is a high level and user friendly
probabilistic model specification
language that we use in our demos
um yeah here i'm i
want to show you an example
just in a second
so you can you can see my screen right
yep maybe
one little size larger or two
i hope it will not break
yeah make it a little larger and then if
it looks unexpected you can pull back
okay here we go
better yep thank you
so here is our example so assume we have
some
moving object uh
it has some hidden states and just
assume that we know it's linear dynamics
for simplicity and we don't we don't
have a direct access to its location but
we have a noisy observation of this
moving object
and we wish to estimate the true
location of this moving object by only
observing its noisy measurements
and we may use a linear multivariate
gaussian state space model
like equations looks like this these are
equivalent notations they're the same
and basically here we say that uh okay
we have a state x at time step k
and it depends only on the previous time
step
through some linear operator a and we
also have a transition noise which is a
gaussian with covariance matrix b and
our observations are
uh
basically modeled also as a gaussian
with
covariance matrix q
so basically this is our model
and we can simply create a factor graph
out of it
and as you can see
that
our model specification resembles very
closely to the equations defined above
so here we have
our state xk and it's modeled as like a
gaussian over previous state with some
let's say known covariance matrices
and this is how we build our model
and under the hood this
code it generates factor graph
uh and we can we can all later on use
reactive
mp.jail api to estimate hidden states of
our system but here's our example it
looks a bit off
probably because i zoomed in a bit
but it's fine i believe
and in this example i perform a kalman
smoother for 500 points and i just
decomposed the
trajectory of this moving object into
two axis x-axis and y-axis
and we can see that
common smoother predicted
like the real hidden states of our
system correctly
even though we have a lot of noise in
our system so these blue dots it's like
our noisy observations
and we go we can go further with this so
because our system is reactive we can we
can estimate uh our our states in real
time
so here's our example let me try to run
it
uh i hope it looks smoothly on my
computer it's actually very smooth like
but i i know that maybe
recording is not that smooth like screen
sharing but here in this example what we
see is that okay we have an infinite
data stream of a moving object the blue
is a real one and the red is an
estimated one and we can see that uh
yeah let me reload it because it's kind
of off
and we can see that
reactive mp is able to perform and
bayesian inference in real time
and it actually adapts to changes in the
environment and also changes the
posterior over the current estimated
state
and we can go even further you probably
notice this orange line here just
inactive for now but we can also
incorporate a prediction
for this model so we can just we can
just extend a little bit our graph
and we can also predict future state of
our system
like this
so now in this example i
do bayesian inference in real time and i
also predict the future state of my
system like in orange
and you can see that prediction also
adapts to the new observations
and yeah it changes basically its future
beliefs
over future states
uh yeah
let me stop it and continue with the
presentation
so um
yeah i'm going to talk about
like when reactive message passing is
available actually it's already working
uh we have a fully working stable
backhand and api for exact and
variational bayesian inference we also
support expectation propagation but that
api is not yet stable so it may change
we support for now only conjugate models
from exponential family
we support extra constraints for
variation optimization procedure
such that form or factorization
constraint
so rocket.jl library it naturally
supports infinite data streams for
example from an internet or from some
sensor
and framework itself is able to handle
missing data
but that
api is also not yet stable
here
some of our future plans for this
platform so we want to extend it to
support non-conjugate models as well
basically foreign lab already supports
it
we just need to carefully port all of
the available existing functionality
from foreign lab to reactive mp
and we also want to integrate with other
probabilistic programming libraries that
exists in july community
reactive message passing gives us an
opportunity to
try to integrate parallel inference
and react in different parts of the
graph simultaneously using like
multi-core capabilities of our cpus
uh
we want to extend
graph ppl to support modular model
specification for now it's unfortunately
not possible
also reactive message passing naturally
gives us an opportunity
to run inference where different data
streams have different update rates
um what
that what i was talking about in the
very beginning about robustness but it's
also interesting how far can we push it
and maybe in it's possible to
automatically adapt model's graph
structure in runtime based on free
energy
but it's like a research project we
don't really know if it's possible or
not for now
uh we we have some ideas about
interactive visualization for message
passing based algorithms
and free energy minimization
visualization
and eventually we we are planning to
release this new platform as a stable
version of formula possibly
in 2.0
and that basically is everything i
wanted to show you in my slides and
thank you for your attention i would
have be happy to answer your questions
awesome first question was is there a
paper on this
reactivemp.jl or how does that work
there is but it's in progress so
it's not publicly available but
we are working on that so there will be
eventually paper about all of this
approach i will describe everything how
it works and how we use it so yeah i
mean of course if anybody writes us an
email who wants an early copy of the
paper i'll be happy to share it if it
stays
confidential i'd be happy to share it
it's very
interesting
development maybe to the other authors
like
what
other um
epochs of forney lab were there
um
how did we get with to this reactive
programming paradigm and also it seems
like you did a lot of the foundational
work in the lab
on the reactive programming
was that just in the julia
implementation or in the more conceptual
grounding
um
yeah we did actually really a lot of
work to support reactive programming in
julia basically julia is is like a young
language and it has no
like good capabilities to run reactive
based like systems so basically we build
it from scratch
yeah but we we used a lot of uh like
let's say
ideas from other programming languages
that we had experience with
i mean i know that the active influence
community uh
matlab and matlab is fantastic
but for
for really for if you want real time
processing of streaming data then julia
is a very good
is a better option because julia is
almost has the syntax of matlab from a
user's
viewpoint
but out of the box it's almost as fast
as c
and so it was a better combination for
if you are in engineering and you
actually want to build
systems that run in real time you want
to make demos and julia is a better
language also uh dimitri also makes use
of some really advanced stuff in julia
it's called multiple dispatch but it
doesn't matter
what it is but it's it's quite advanced
and it's not
uh available in in matlab but it's
extremely useful for what we do
for do with the
toolbox it's it seems to be
if you look at a graph and message
passing it see it seems to be like oh
this is actually not so hard to
implement
but there's a reason why there are
extremely few toolboxes for factor
graphs okay microsoft has built one
infer.net and it's it's great but it's
not really a real-time toolbox
um and so as far as we know we are
there's not much competition at the
moment for us
not that our toolbox is very advanced
yet but
um i don't see a lot of people working
on this i see a lot of people working on
multicarter sampling but multi-car
sampling will not work for the
sizes of systems and for the real-time
data streams that we want to do with
active inference right we are
working with systems where we want to
make actions and influence our data
so this is a real time system
um
and so we have to go to
want to actually scale up we have to go
to
build a really high quality professional
toolbox
that automates message passing i hope
this will be uh one of those toolboxes
and hopefully will also be other
toolboxes but
yeah that's why we're doing this
very interesting answer
how has the
dialogue between
the math and programming and computer
science side and then the active
inference side been like what has
each side kind of contributed because it
sounds like some of those real time
insights of active inference are kind of
propagating back to the design of
algorithms and then
we we see both directions so how has
that played out maybe for any of each or
each of you
i can also answer maybe this question
from my point of view i mostly like
doing programming uh
but i still learn something new every
time because we like in this constant uh
dialogue with
math guys in our lab let's say and i
learn something new every day and of
course it reflects like our design
choices for our software as well
so it's kind of but sometimes it's it's
very hard to fit this high level
mathematical ideas to the actual
implementation
and also it's very hard to make it
efficient
so
yeah we are not uh we're not done with
this um i mean the toolbox is available
for anybody and and
all the nice territory examples the
basic thermostat the tic tac toe and it
all works very smooth
um
our
hope is that with reactive message
passing we can actually
you know get a
path to scaling this up to to serious
applications
and that i mean that's real i mean we're
an engineering group we want to build
systems that really do something
useful i also work for a hearing aid
company so i want to build real time
audio processing algorithms
and
and others may want to use this for
robotics so
yeah but and that's not going to work in
in real time model up it's not going to
work
um yeah a bit with all the multi-card or
something so
this is our effort
and it's quite
it's takes a long time because it's very
multidisciplinary efforts right we have
in in my group we have a mathematicians
and
neuroscientists and
computer scientists because it's it's
it's it's difficult
there's a lot of different
expertises
that that you need to build a good
toolbox for active inference
i think because it's so difficult there
is a lot of like
um like cross
fertilization between the active
inference community and the engineering
that we do
the community is mostly interested in
explaining biological systems right the
the energy principle and active
inference as
a model for biology
and i think that's very interesting
because while nature has a certain way
of doing things
efficiently um
and if this is a model for that
then it's also a good idea to take that
to engineering
and that's kind of our recommend so we
kind of take the ideas that are
available in the active inference
community and where they explain brains
and think about brains
and think hey how can we take these
ideas
and
use them to build an engineering system
and i think that's kind of the main
yeah the main interaction between it and
hopefully then we build tools that
the community can also use then in their
research eventually
what that made me think about was
it's really a reframing of some of the
main challenges like seeing signal
processing as a real-time event or
seeing
the causal relationships between action
and future data all these kinds of
reframings of the problem it's not like
the active inference
algorithms
take massive matrix uh calculations to
do per se they can be very simple or not
but it's actually that reframing in the
the embedding of action within every
step
that then ends up solving the scaling
some of the scaling challenges some of
the resilience challenges because like
resilience of a
transportation network in a city they
would do
sampling or they would take something
that's an unfolding dynamic process and
then try to roll out a million
iterations of it statically
so it's again it's not that the
calculations
inside of the loop have to be
challenging it's just a reframing of
prioritizing action
ended up
going down these roads of scaling and
real-time capacity
yeah i i like that
the thought um perhaps i can say
something about it in the
context of what i work on because i work
on designing basically i'm a hearing aid
engineer i work on
[Music]
and if you ask a hearing aid engineer
signal processing engineer so what is
your task
well our task is to build the best
hearing aid algorithm
and
so
then what happens is that
a hearing aid client goes to the store
and buys a hearing aid usually
it's very happy and goes out and then
two weeks later sits in the restaurant i
cannot understand
her conversation partner because
there's noise and this wasn't expected
and there's nothing she can do
because you can't ask a client a hearing
aid client to
to
fiddle with hearing aid parameters so if
this happens
a few times
um then she throws or she puts her
hearing aid in the drawer and this uh
indeed about 10 20 percent of hearing
aids end up in the drawer they're very
expensive and
[Music]
ends up not being used a really
sad statistic
so rather
you can you can turn it around and say
okay what is the real hearing aid design
problem the real hearing aid design
problem is send somebody out with any
hearing aid but what do you do when
she's unhappy in the field
at in the restaurant
and what we want to build is an agent
that will
then so she just slaps her wrist raceway
i'm happy and now this agent needs to
make an action and give her new
parameter settings that are
the most interesting for her and and and
and the in the best
compromise between information seeking
and goal-driven gold riven being making
her happy
so
hearing a design from my viewpoint now
is just build an agent that will
make actions make hearing aid proposals
when she's unhappy
and if she
right she's unhappy and then hearing a
mixed proposal says no that's not good
well the agent gives another proposal
and that is okay that's better and then
we move on and maybe a week later the
same event and this goes on continually
but there is at least
a procedure to keep moving on to keep
improving over time right
so that's
the the real thing of design is the is
then the the action in the field in c2
which is very different from what's
currently happening which is hearing aid
engineers sitting at the desk
with model up not in the environment
so that's a it's it's a paradigm shift
and active inference agents
can maybe make that happen and could
really
i think uh
create a pivoting point for something
like signal processing design
which is uh
you know it's not something that you
think about when you're a neuroscientist
but this could really mean something big
for engineering
and not just for signal processing but
also in different engineering
disciplines and
so that's why i think over time you'll
see more and more people coming from
different fields
getting an interest in this uh
active inference and the free energy
principle
uh even even uh non
the not neuroscientists right but
engineers yeah
yeah cool we hope so and and that really
reminds me of the pragmatic turn
which is it's a little bit like a
horseshoe theory with the engineers and
the philosophers
often talking about pragmatism
in different ways different communities
different tools
and now there's a way to kind of close
that gap or at least map across it
where we can embed some of those
insights about
really an activism the role of design
science anticipatory design science with
take it or leave it philosophy or
there's the toolkit to develop
maybe it's interesting five years after
working with a toolkit or maybe five
years of philosophy and then you're
curious about the toolkit
so one
question was
how do these graphs account for
temporally deep models how are those
specified
or what
make what is different about the graph
because it's just calculating the next
action to take in the examples that you
provided
maybe guys you can show your graph again
how how the future is represented
um and how do you add temporal thickness
to that for example that's kind of so if
you have if you have a graph
like
chair screen yes
if you have a graph like this then how
do you add temporal thickness for
example
um that's that's just about adding
layers
so
what is shown here is one layer
and this layer
it acts
at a certain clock time you know
observations come in discretely
um
but you might have a layer above this
that is somehow connected to this layer
below
that acts at a higher temporal time
scale
so it evolves slower
but it regulates or influences the
parameters
of for example a transition model here
or an observation model here
so you get a time varying
observation model that is influenced
by
a slower evolving layer
on top of that you can get an even
slower evolving layer right and that's
that's the way
you can build hierarchies
um
and actually there's um also a pg
student in our group ismael senos who
has done some very interesting work on
that and he has investigated how you
make hierarchical
gaussian filters um so hierarchical
gaussian systems where you have one top
layer influencing the variance
of the transition model of the layer
below
and
you can see that you can get
can model very natural signals with that
so so in nature you have you have
signals that are time varying the
statistics there their time varying and
the statistics of those models
are time varying
so a hierarchical model in that sense
can be very useful for that and of
course that's that's yeah of course
also how our brains are structured so
again there you have this inspiration
from nature
um on how to structure
the models that we try to build
um
with vector graphs
at least in theory they should be pretty
easy
because you can just connect them you
can connect layer on top of that and and
see how it behaves
and eventually the complexity of your
model will become very high and you will
get penalized for that automatically so
there will be a cutoff point
um given your data and that will be the
optimal amount of layers that you need
in order to explain away all the
variants
that you observe
so so that's kind of how we think about
temporal thickness
and and
time dependence and dynamical models
like these
then can i share my screen also yep
sure okay yeah let's see
because this um awesome
yeah
this is a graph from a paper
a few years back uh in frontiers
um it's called i think uh
deep temporal models inspect factor
graphs or something
and here you see a three layer system i
mean don't bother about the details now
but here you see at the top layer just
just basically has one one section one
time step
and in that time step at the top layer
you have
two
observations or two steps at the
middleware
i need uh yeah
i'm not sure if you can see my uh
okay and then again for the let's say
the third layer whenever the middle
layer tips takes one step we have two
steps here so so there is sort of a
finer granularity
at each layer right and so we can build
hierarchical
uh models really and uh so we're doing
that also in uh i mean also yeah if you
you
you look at some of the papers on our
website you'll find a lot of babies on
the hierarchical gaussian filter from
chris matisse we've implemented that
in in
but also um
i mean you can also do it for active
influence things like uh and it will
look
like this uh
thomas pyre has also graphs like this in
some of his papers
very interesting and we see a lot of the
same variables like g
d b
like we can it's kind of a different
representation of active inference so
yeah
this is kind of also going back i think
to the earlier frontiers paper what are
some of the big equivalencies
or kind of like airtight mappings
from into
forney factor graphs
because there's probably some broad
areas of application
that could almost be hot swapped for
this underlying it perhaps
so what like are the equivalencies with
just bayesian graphs in general versus
factor graphs versus other
topics at that level
i think a foreign style vector graph or
a bipartite graph or a beijing network
they aren't really different
they can be used as
they're just a representation
of a factorized model
and the way you represent that
can have an impact about how you think
about those models
so for example if you choose a 4-install
effective graph representation it's very
suited for signal processing because you
kind of can see these messages as
signals that flow over your graph
so for us as engineers
this is a very intuitive representation
in bayesian networks it's a bit more
the model representation itself is more
compact in that sense that you only have
variable notes and you see how they
relate so it gives you a good idea of
model structure
so it can be very nice to
have a quick overview of model like that
and then you have for example a
bipartite graph which also shows a
relation between variables as an
additional kind of
vector node in between
um and it goes it gives you a bit more
granularity on how these are connected
and gives you room to talk about well
what is the relationship between these
variables
and so in the end they're equivalent
you can take one model and represent it
in three different ways maybe even more
but i think it does impact the way how
you think
or how you think about these models so
um
that
that usually comes up when writing a
paper
and then you have to think okay what is
actually the best representation for my
idea
sometimes it's about budget graph
sometimes it's a visual network
sometimes it's for install photograph
um
it just depends by your story yeah
hopefully
i do find though i mean in my experience
when we think about systems and a whole
set of equations if you read that in a
paper
or if you write it down um it gives more
insight if you draw to me it gives more
insight if i draw the graph
and
there is an x
there must be an exact correspondence
between the
the graph and the equations and very
often if you draw the graph and then you
write down the equations there's not an
x-axis corresponding so you learn from
it you you you basically you know there
must be an exact correspondence and
basically you you often find out you
have an error in your equations or in
your graph
but i think uh
like the the end goal the end goal uh
is of to make the toolbox a toolbox for
let's say for the community to design
their own active influence agents and
what i
envisioned there is something like
simulink i'm not sure or labview i'm not
sure if people are familiar with that
but um
these are graphical models you want to
actually also define them graphically
and you want to have a palette with
notes and just
draw your graph and say this is my model
and now go run
you don't want to worry about the
inference the inference is under the
root dependence passing should be done
by
the designers of the toolbox but you
should just be thinking about your
graphical structure that's the uh
and this one and connect it
with your mouse to your microphone of
your computer or to your camera
and maybe to uh
you know there's also connectors in the
toolbox for robots and then
it should just go right
that's going to be the bob ross of
graphs
that's how you want to design i think
right you just want to draw the brain
and at least the generative model of the
brain and just let it go
and don't worry about how inference
takes place
what what you just said there about
viewing the equation and then maybe
going from the pen and paper to the
programming language to the graphical
representation and then kind of
cross-checking it's like when you
reverse translate languages and you're
when you lock in where two words map
back to each other you know you've
you've made a map but if you're on this
infinite loop you're you're lost in the
word space so when you move across
sectors like that or across modalities
with the
analytical the simulations on the
computer and then the graphical it kind
of embeds action
in what otherwise might be seen as a
knowledge
product a product of inference and then
a final action
and that's a similar fallacy to
train the dynamic process in a snapshot
and then expect that it's going to work
in real time so it's like embedding this
real time flow
in that the production of knowledge yeah
yes yes we are important yeah yeah
um yeah we're implementing active
insurance while we are trying to design
this stuff that's true yeah
yeah one one general question was just
about factorization
so
the factorization the
way we go about it is starting with our
intuition and looking for residuals or
how of all the ways to factorize a model
do we find one that works
yeah there's two kinds of factorizations
there's a factorization in let's say in
the generative model
right that's the graph that we draw
and so i mean let's say most people
uh or the most common models are these
these
these markov models right where you you
kind of retain a current state that
summarizes everything that happens in
the past
uh and you use that current state to
basically to yeah to summarize the past
and then that's all the information have
about the past so you don't need to
remember the past you just remember your
state
and with that and you did make a new
observation you combine the information
make a new state
and so forth there so hidden markov
models
palmdps all these models have that same
structure these these this
microstructure so that's for the
generative model of these dynamic
systems
then there is a second question if we
now do inference
um and um yeah then there's often what
we call the mean field assumption for
the variational posterior but there are
also
variants on that structured green field
so you can you can
still decide if you want your posterior
to be even more structured or let's say
even more factorized than the
generative model
but in the end yeah it's a
it's a proposal
uh
you just run it and if you have another
proposal you just run it and the one
that has the lowest free energy wins
that's uh that's it right the challenge
is to automate that process
go from the
let's say the poorer structure to the
better structures
just by failing to minimization just by
message passing in real time without
stopping the whole process doing an
analysis
right it should just keep moving right
it should just just structure adaptation
should be like state estimation it just
keeps moving over time there's no
resetting
maybe there's a bit of a
thing like
a dreaming stage right but
the principle time moves on
and that's the challenge and we don't
know that in our factory class but yeah
we
i mean
we have one hd student who is currently
looking into that
yeah like as an engineer i think um the
question is well what what do you start
out with what will be your initial model
proposal uh so if you talk about
factorizations of your generative model
you think uh every factor then it kind
of represents a prior distribution or
conditional distribution and that's how
you kind of build up your model
where do you start
and it starts with how you believe
the world generates observations
in that sense you think about
what is the causal structure
of the environment and you might have
some idea about how physics works
um or how
states transition in in your environment
or at least how you believe this
transition and that's kind of where you
start
and you think okay well
maybe let's try a very coarse note this
minus one for example in my talk let's
try that here because i don't really
know what i want to put there but i have
to put something let's try something
and see how that works it kind of models
how i believe the world works
and that's that's how you start out
and then you start thinking well i
actually know a bit more about it i'm
not satisfied with how this model
proposed how this model works um and i
can change this minus one for example
with uh with something that's a bit more
complex because i know the physics i
know how
these uh
how temperature integrates with distance
for example and i can build that in
um so that's how you go to a second
proposal
and it's always inspired by
uh how you believe
the causal structure of the world is um
is uh yeah is
how that works so in that sense it's
kind of theory building you're building
a theory or an explanation of your
environment
and
well maybe if you're really really good
if you have an excellent model then you
can find something that
kind of improves upon the state of the
art because you can always improve
just find something that gives you a
lower free energy or better model
performance in that sense
um and you can keep tweaking and
tweaking
um
these models and these factorizations
and
things like that
yeah
free energy
minimization
has been described or just as a way to
rank the different models and as an
imperative on these multiple different
fronts how do we know that
free energy minimization is making the
policy
that
is going to be like resilient is there a
way where similar to a local
optimization getting trapped somewhere
in a bigger optimization space
there might be some avenue of free
energy minimization that
makes the system just like break down
like we'll get there faster let's just
accelerate and then
there's some
kind of one-time failure of the system
i'm just wondering how can one
metric that's a number you know and can
be sorted how can it evaluate such
radically different
chess strategies or driving
approaches at the end it's just
probability theory and probability is
also just a number right
and the energy kind of
it approximates your evidence which is
the probability according to your model
of observing the data so if you make a
model that gives you the best evidence
then it's a good explanation for for
your for your data
so in the end it's just
you try to do
approximate probability theory
um
and free energy
is then bound upon your evidence and it
also takes into account
this posterior divergence term which
kind of
says the price that you pay for
approximating bayesian inference
so it has two parts to it it has
um the model evidence part
and it has the posterior divergence part
and both play a role one says okay um
this is
the quality of my solution it's it's how
well
uh
your model explains the data that you
observe you can get you can get a number
for that the surprise or the negative
log modal evidence
and you have the other part of stereo
divergence that says
well this is the price and information
that you pay for making this
approximation you can also put a number
on that
it's just a chaotic versions that you
evaluate
um and then you add those two and you
get a number
um
so yeah so the question is how can one
number kind of
represent
everything in terms of quality
well you might care about different
things than how well your model predicts
or evaluates the observations right
and then if you care about other things
um
then then
yep then then you might use different
number but
um in our in our sense in our in our uh
in our work
yeah we're kind of
uh
we want to have this bayesian measure of
quality
yeah
i don't know if that really answers your
question but it's it's it's still a good
question it's um
it's kind of is is free energy or that
number that you get is that enough
right
that's that's kind of what's behind this
and probability theory says yes but if
you apply it in practice then you care
about maybe other things you care about
how many people survive before how many
you know
how many how many mistakes you uh you
you cash from from something and if you
care about that well then you should use
that as a performance metric
i i think right i mean it's uh
the energy of course has has has many
decompositions right in in in
complexity minus accuracy and
and and surprise minus uh
minus the kl divergence
um but
to
i'm not sure if i interpret the question
correctly but if you say like how do you
know that it does well
in in practice in the field
well you don't right um
the
and look the only uh
thing you can say is that i mean what
the system does it will look for
a configuration that minimizes free
energy but you don't know what you don't
know you don't know if there is another
model that would do better if we haven't
simulated that model then we don't know
and um
the only learning opportunities there
are
is to generate errors so um
the only way to really improve the model
is to actually
hit indeed um let's say situations where
it's not working
and then you need to adapt your
parameters and and
and even more over time you have to
structure so
yeah it's uh
i mean building a good system is a
process
right it's not a
matter of uh just
you have to be extremely lucky if you
just
build a system that and it completely
works right
uh
it's what this
this between this orbitals active
influence describes is a process towards
a better
systems but not
it doesn't describe a system that
doesn't make mistakes in fact it needs
the mistakes to learn
and it describes the process
awesome points it's that operational
insight that if you're getting 100 on
the test like something is
at the very best less than informative
at the very worst you're you're way down
the wrong path and um and then it
reminded me of like a grocery store is
it that we're ranking the different
objects according to one measure
no not really it's like balancing
strategies
for
finding preference and that's where all
of these assumptions like the
factorization and the mean field and
it's not guaranteed to give you the best
object every time and there's still the
stochasticity of the real world and the
ability of the grocery store to change
like it's not the end of the story
it's actually just
a practice in a process that
has some of those features of reactive
graphs and biological systems
that's right yeah
well um if any of you have any final
comments this was just really one of the
coolest times to learn about this
but
you're always welcome back to join any
time as a participant or to present and
if you have any final comments you can
note them
well it was a
real pleasure to be here and uh
if we have new stuff we would love to
come back i think it's a fantastic
fantastic show here or show it's a
forum or whatever it's properly called
but i really enjoy it and we really
enjoyed being part of it
and uh thanks a lot for the discussion
some some food for thought there as well
it's really cool
good question for every opportunity to
present yes
great
okay until next time bye